let's start today with some meaty policy
analysis when it comes to taxing the
rich please don't tune out no no no
don't click away no in all seriousness
this morning I watched a little bit of
our friend Sam Cedar's appearance on the
Patrick Bet David show a program I did a
month or six weeks ago or so and one of
the topics that came up with them was
about what should tax rates be and
taxing the rich and Sam says yes and
Patrick says no and okay I don't want in
this segment to delve into the should we
or shouldn't we or the morals of the
ethics what I simply want to address
here is if we wanted to tax the ultra
wealthy more
how would we do it effectively and what
I mean by effectively is it's very easy
to say raise the top income tax rate but
then you realize wait a second a lot of
the ultra wealthy aren't earning income
in wages subject to that rate so that's
not really going to help and in the
background of all of this is the news
that Democratic senators as HuffPost
reports are urging the Biden
Administration to go after what they
call ultra wealthy tax Dodgers most of
this is specifically related to using
trusts and other Financial Vehicles when
it comes to inheritance when it comes to
inheritance and what we might call a
state tax or some like to call it the
death tax so what I want to do in this
segment just to provide a little bit of
food for thought is give a bunch of
different changes that could be made to
the tax code
that would help tax the ultra wealthy
now I know that many of you are going to
write to me and you're going to say but
David that method wouldn't work because
of this reason and this other method
wouldn't work because of that other
reason this is very much like when we
look at an issue like gun violence no
one policy would cover all mass
shootings and prevent every single one
when we talk about uh waiting periods
mandatory liability insurance limiting
certain Firearms only to those over age
25 requiring re-licensing and more
extensive training right we have this
list that I've put together of 10 to 12
different items that could be put in
place
no single one would prevent every mass
shooting and in a country of 330 million
people 340 million people no matter what
you do there might still be some mass
shootings but the point is what's the
lowest hanging fruit what can we do to
in the case of the tax element
collect more from the ultra wealthy so
here's the list and I'll tell you how
they would work and their limits and
again no there's no Silver Bullet here
so okay should we raise the top marginal
income tax rate yeah we probably should
saying that at I don't remember where it
is right now 550 000 or so dollars a
year you hit the top tax rate of 37
percent and from there up there's no
more brackets and no higher marginal tax
rates that's probably too too low there
should probably be some more brackets
with some higher rates but that won't
get us all of that Ultra Rich tax
revenue that we might be seeking because
a lot of the ultra wealthy aren't
earning money via wages they're also
able to reduce taxes through deductions
and tax credits Etc okay so one tool is
you raise the top marginal tax rate it's
not going to do everything you want it
to do secondly you can look at imposing
a wealth tax on certain Assets Now that
is going to it's quite difficult to
implement I'm honestly not even
completely sure that it would pass all
legal muster but it's an idea that's
been proposed you impose a wealth tax to
try to get it taxation of assets rather
than just income now what are the
problems well what do you do about
illiquid assets do you tax the value of
Fine Art who determines what the Fine
Art is worth you probably have to
exclude an asset like Fine Art and so
what this leads to is that those who
hold valuable assets can either move
assets to countries with no wealth taxes
invest in assets that are difficult to
value or would be Exempted like artwork
or rare Collectibles okay but it might
do something and to be clear I'm not
necessarily advocating for every single
one of these policies I'm telling you
what is on the what is in the toolbox so
to speak number three there are tax
loopholes that could be closed one such
loophole is the so-called carried
interest loophole however
there would be some ultra wealthy folks
who will find ways to get around that
either moving the types of assets that
would have previously benefited benefit
benefited from the carried interest
loophole into non-taxable assets like
municipal bonds not totally realistic
for the hedge fund managers that that
would be targeted at admittedly looking
at changing business structure moving
certain assets offshore lobbying for a
new different loophole the next time
there's a friendly Administration so is
it a Panacea no but is it a tool
absolutely number four
increasing IRS funding to do more audits
of the ultra wealthy now there are some
people in that income bracket that are
doing everything right it's not like
with all of these folks if they were
audited the government would find that
they have underpaid their taxes so for
those who are legally and correctly
avoiding taxes auditing them isn't going
to make a difference but we know that
there is significant underpayment in
that group and having a more well-funded
IRS not with agents with guns Just audit
agents to do audits would certainly uh
claw back some of that Revenue that
should have been paid a financial
transaction tax if you put in place a
financial transaction tax the ultra
wealthy who might not earn any income
and pay very little as far as income
taxes go
but are involved in financial
transactions they would have to pay a
tax on those transactions and as with
anything else they could look at
stopping the financial transactions in
order to not generate those taxable
events moving assets offshore to
countries that don't have such attacks
or investing in assets not subjected to
that tax certainly could do it but it is
another tool
raising capital gains if you are worried
about not collecting tax revenue from
the ultra wealthy because they are
earning money that is subject to capital
gains rather than income tax you could
raise the tax on capital gains it's not
a silver bullet you could avoid that tax
as an ultra-rich person by waiting to
take any gains or through other
mechanisms an alternative minimum tax
Alternative Minimum Tax says listen if
this is your income before deductions no
matter how many deductions you take
there is a minimum level of tax that you
have to pay you can't deduct and credit
your way all the way down below some
certain amount that's a good idea High
earners might still be able to reduce
their taxable income significantly
through the tools that do remain
available but it's an it's a tool the
Alternative Minimum Tax you could look
at increasing corporate taxes that is a
great idea that being said you have to
remember that that only applies to
certain types of Corporations s
corporations and LLCs and sole
proprietorships those are what are
called pass-through type entities and
those are governed by the personal
income tax rate not by the corporate tax
rate but certainly it would make a
difference so these are all tools that
are available every single one
is at risk of being circumvented at
least partially depending on what tax
methods and uh strategies you use but
taken together much like doing 10 or 12
different things about gun safety it
would have a significant impact in its
totality now this is a separate issue
from as I discussed on the Patrick Bet
David show I'm not immediately looking
to just raise all sorts of taxes what I
think is the really the lowest hanging
fruit is number one what are we getting
for the taxes we already pay what are
the taxes being used for and secondly
getting actually closer to the tax rates
that are in place simply by focusing on
deductions credits and loopholes but
that's a subject subject for a different
day last item about this any time that
there's a tax proposal
and you hear oh this would raise 10
billion or whatever the case may be it's
really important to understand whether
that estimate of this would generate 10
billion dollars in tax revenue is it
based on a dynamic scoring system and
what I mean by that is it's very easy to
say based on the way people filed their
taxes last year if we put in place this
new tax it would generate 10 billion
dollars what needs to be taken into
account is that last year if this tax
had been in place
people might have used the different tax
strategy in response to the fact that
that tax was put in place so whenever we
examine this type of proposal of any
kind when it comes to taxes you want to
dynamically score what it would do by
accounting for how people's behavior
might change send me your thoughts is
this interesting to people let me know
the state of Arkansas
continues to waste the time and
resources of the people in the state Now
by restricting School bathroom use by
transgender people under the leadership
if you can call it that of Republican
Governor Sarah Huckabee Sanders they
have banned CRT from schools which
wasn't being taught in schools and they
are generally wasting a ton of time and
now the news is yes indeed Governor
Sarah Huckabee Sanders signed a new law
prohibiting trans people at public
schools from using the restroom of their
choice voice this would make Arkansas
the fourth place to put such
restrictions on public schools and it
requires that those that individuals use
the bathroom that match I believe the
wording they're using is their birth sex
um Alabama Oklahoma and Tennessee have
filed similar restrictions although
lawsuits have been filed and this is
something that is growing and growing
and growing here's where I want to focus
today on this issue it's really
important to talk about the absurdity of
the bathroom issue there is simply no
evidence that trans people in public
bathrooms pose a threat to the safety of
others whether we're talking about kids
adults in schools out at restaurants in
malls or whatever the case may be one of
the big arguments really the biggest
argument that the right makes is that if
anybody can just use whatever bathroom
they want based on their alleged their
stated gender identity
it opens the door to stalking and sexual
assault and pedophilia and all sorts of
different things there is absolutely no
evidence that that is the case and in
fact when you look at the data there are
widespread studies about this Studies
have shown that trans people are way
more likely to be the victims of
violence and the victims of harassment
in public restrooms than they are to be
the perpetrators there's a 2013 study
from UCLA School of Law it finds 70
percent of trans respondents were
verbally harassed or assaulted or
mistreated in public restrooms a 2016
report by the Human Rights Campaign
found that 59 percent of trans people
avoided using public restrooms in the
preceding year because they were afraid
of those negative experiences and
there's a 2018 study from the AAP the
American Academy of Pediatrics which
finds trans people and gender
non-conforming youth are more likely to
experience verbal and physical abuse in
school restrooms on the other side of
this there is absolutely no study that
finds that when you look at incidents of
harassment sexual assault Etc in public
bathrooms that trans people are over
represented relative to their population
there is just no data that can support
that cause
and then there's the last aspect to this
if your concern is sexual assault or
harassment or whatever the case may be
it is already illegal
it does your gender identity doesn't
matter your genitalia doesn't matter it
is already illegal to engage in sexual
assault or harassment or stalking or
photography or whatever the case may be
in public restrooms doesn't matter which
bathroom you're in the gender identity
of the individuals involved also doesn't
matter and the law is applied equally
whether you are cisgender or transgender
the law is already there and there is no
evidence that trans people are more
likely to commit
sexual assault or harassment than
cisgender people so the entire framework
here is a moral panic and fear framework
as is often the case with right Wingers
they don't have the facts on their side
because the facts aren't on their side
and so it's based on fear and the idea
quite frankly the idea that they want to
tell you is that Hulk Hogan is going to
put on a wig go into a public bathroom
and harass little girls that's the idea
the the image that these folks want you
to believe it's not happening there is
no data that backs this up as an actual
danger and Sarah Huckabee Sanders just
continues wasting time on this complete
and utter nonsense
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
well despite the sunshine and warmth of
the State of Florida Ron DeSantis is
experiencing significant shrinkage
in the polls even though he hasn't even
announced that he's running for
president in 2024 and he may not Ron
DeSantis over the last several weeks has
seen a pretty significant decline in the
polls which we're going to look at in a
moment why is this going on well there's
an interesting article in the week by
Rafi Schwartz and it looks like it looks
at a couple of different aspects to this
and one of the things that this article
mentions
um quotes political con consultant and
commentator Simon Rosenberg who says
that the successes that DeSantis has had
in Florida are actually alienating him
from voters in background Battleground
States still stinging from Republican
losses by the candidates who embraced
the right most reaches of the political
Spectrum Schwartz writes it's into this
Dynamic that DeSantis has quote decided
to become even more Maga super Maga the
end result is that for Republicans
hoping DeSantis would be a reasonable
and capable alternative to Trump this
has been a very bad week that is one
perspective that actually he is he is
going Beyond Maga it's too much Maga for
Maga and the voters in Battleground
States aside from whatever Floridian
Republicans say about DeSantis aren't
super thrilled I think that that's one
part of it secondly the idea of DeSantis
was very appealing as an alternative to
Trump six to eight months ago but
increasingly as DeSantis is more
publicly visible he just was interviewed
by Piers Morgan we're going to look at
clips from that his lack of Charisma and
his complete uh we'll leave it there his
lack of Charisma is starting to become
apparent to voters who are sort of being
deflated by that they were excited about
the Santa's now they've seen what the
scientist is really like and they're
like I don't know this isn't really that
great uh the hill reports desantises
lowest level of support since December
in new poll
Trails Trump by 28 points and in fact
there are a number of polls that are
really not looking good for DeSantis
there is a BC rated premise poll which
has Trump up 24 uh with registered
voters there
um is a yougov poll that has Trump up
15. there is a Monmouth poll in uh that
has Trump up 52 certainly a difficult
one to believe I have to say but that
that's what it says
um a morning consult poll has Trump up
28 that's the one that was referenced it
it's really not looking good here for
Ron DeSantis so the question we were
previously asking with Donald Trump was
can Trump make it to the primary
insofar as indictments could derail him
or whatever else might be the case with
DeSantis the question is less about can
you make it to the primaries it can even
make it into the race now I've
previously talked about what some of you
have suggested which is DeSantis is
really young
um yeah
why not just wait why not just wait
until 2028 he doesn't have to run right
now Trump won't be a factor no matter
what happens in 2028 maybe 48 or 49 year
old DeSantis should look at running in
a month ago my view was he's not going
to be able to look at the polling
numbers and get away because he would be
saying to himself I might not have this
opportunity in 28 as the numbers decline
for DeSantis maybe 28 starts to look
more attractive now what one other thing
I would love to say that DeSantis is
dangerous authoritarian Tendencies are
the reason why he's failing in the polls
but Trump has all of those same
authoritarian Tendencies so that's not
actually what it is I I do think that
there is something to the idea of
DeSantis is becoming the reality of
DeSantis and a lot of people don't
really like it so Trump aside DeSantis
is dangerous DeSantis is doing better
against uh Biden than Trump is doing so
in a sense it's probably good for the
left for DeSantis not to do well in the
primary on the other hand DeSantis
bailing
might make Trump's path easier which has
its own downsides in that he may end up
in the general election less weakened
and sort of more ready to go but that a
lot of things are going to happen
between now and when the general
election starts so shrinkage for Ron
DeSantis let's now talk about a story
that is bringing together Trump and
DeSantis which is very very interesting
Republicans are increasingly demanding
suggesting that Ron DeSantis block the
extradition of Donald Trump from Florida
to New York if indeed Donald Trump is
indicted and arrested in the state of
New York as many of us believe he might
be I guess although it was supposed to
happen Tuesday and then Wednesday and
then it didn't happen put that aside for
a moment more and more Republicans are
making the request that DeSantis block
the extradition of trump to New York can
DeSantis even do this well that's a good
question we'll get to that in a moment
first here is Florida Republican
Congressman Matt Gates May making the
case if I were governor of Florida I
would not allow any Floridian to be
hauled before some soros-backed
prosecutor in some blue City over
politics and I wouldn't make an
exception to not protect the president
of the United States Ron DeSantis should
be standing in the breach to stop any
sort of extradition of President Trump
from the state of Florida and the fact
that he's not doing so puts every
Floridian at risk who could be the
subject of a false allegation I know Ron
DeSantis well he's a friend but he
hasn't been the target of false and
persistent allegations like President
Trump has and so I don't think he really
understands the nature of this fight
right now I think that it was a bit
uncouth for him to take a jab at the
former president and there's a role for
the governor of Florida here I think to
stand up for our state for the rule of
law and to push back against the
sorosization of the criminal justice
system so is it actually something that
Ron DeSantis can do I will tell you in a
moment Charlie Kirk making the exact
same case about this extradition and
everybody is on message with the Soros
stuff you will notice why doesn't Ron
DeSantis create a sanctuary state for a
former president under political
persecution
if the left is able to create Sanctuary
States for rapists and murderers Thugs
and criminals
I don't think it's too big of an ass for
Ron DeSantis critic to create a
sanctuary state for a former president
who's being persecuted
by a Soros funded D.A yeah so it's an
interesting legal question can a
governor block the extradition of an
indicted person from their state to the
state in which they are indicted can a
governor do that Governors do have the
power to block extradition of a person
who is wanted in another state but in
very limited circumstances a governor
May block the extradition of a person if
the governor determines that the
person's rights would be violated in the
extradition or if the governor believes
that the request for extradition is
politically motivated or improper now
that just happens to be
exactly what these right Wingers are
claiming they are saying that the the
prosecution of trump if it happens
is politically motivated would be
politically motivated however it is not
that the governor just says yep it's
politically motivated so there's no
extradition if a governor asserts that
they are blocking extradition from their
state to another for that reason it can
be challenged in court and ultimately
it's up to courts to determine whether
extraditions should be allowed
from everything I've read right now
there is every indication that if
DeSantis tried to block Trump's
extradition from Florida to New York on
these grounds courts would say you can't
do it also worth noting Governors cannot
block extradition to another country
that falls under Federal jurisdiction so
it's a nice little pipe dream that
Charlie Kirk and Matt Gates have but it
is very unlikely to be what keeps Trump
out of the state of New York and by the
way Trump's lawyers have already said he
would surrender will it happen uh will
the arrest happen that's a different
question I've been telling you for a
while Ron DeSantis is dangerous and part
of what makes him dangerous is that he
has a lot of the same terrible
authoritarian instincts of Donald Trump
but he is more able to potentially get
things done and less cartoonishly
unhinged appears Morgan interviewed Ron
DeSantis and remember that Rhonda santis
is experiencing significant shrinkage in
the polls he hasn't actually announced
that he's running yet so this is all
very speculative and very hypothetical
but one of the interesting questions
that was asked by Piers Morgan during
this interview was what are the actual
differences between you and Trump other
Republican candidates and potential
candidates have said there really are no
differences other than identity
Nikki Haley said well I'm younger and a
woman and Indian
Tim Scott said I don't know that I have
any policy differences but here is Ron
desantis's answer to that question what
do you think of the differences well I
mean I think there's a few things I mean
obviously you know the the approach to
covid was different I mean you know I
would have fired somebody like fauci I
think that he got way too big for his
britches and I think he did a lot of
damage I also think just in terms of my
approach to leadership you know I get
Personnel in the government who have the
agenda of the people and share our
agenda if you bring your own agenda in
you're gone we're just not going to have
that so the way we run the government I
think is no daily drama focus on the big
picture and put points on the board and
I think that that's something that's
very important so DeSantis is
essentially saying the difference is our
style and I would have fired fauci not
exactly a big gap between him and Donald
Trump interestingly enough uh Piers
Morgan did ask Ron DeSantis his views on
the nicknames that Trump has come up for
him who's your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving you so far is it wrong
Rhonda sanctimonious or meet more
I can't even he went off meatball wrong
I can't uh I don't know how to spell the
sanctimonies I don't really know what it
means but I you know I kind of like it's
long it's got a lot of valve I mean so
we go with that that's fine you know
isn't this fun guys you call me and you
can call me whatever you want I mean
just as long as you you know also call
me a winner right right DeSantis is the
winner asked whether he believes if he
were to run oh sorry no I want to do
Putin next the topic of Vladimir Putin
came up and this is very interesting
we'll see a view of pizza
look I think he's got Grand Ambitions I
think he's hostile to the United States
but I think the thing that we've seen is
he doesn't have the conventional
capability to realize his Ambitions and
so he's basically a gas station with a
bunch of nuclear weapons and so for us
one of the things we could be doing
better is utilizing our own energy
resources in the United States we could
be permitting natural gas pipelines from
Marcellus doing a lot in in Alaska
that's where he gets all his power and
obviously he's influenced Europe uh by
by having so much energy so the way to
hit Putin is to hit him with energy but
I do think you look back all the defense
analysts and me in the past we
overestimated his conventional
capability this has been a huge blunder
for him uh huge costs and uh you know
we'll see what ends up happening with
his longevity and and power but but this
has been a this has been a loss for them
there is a move now to hold him
accountable for war crimes bombing
maternity hospitals and genocidal
activity in parts of Ukraine it's wiping
out whole cities maripole and others
which you support that I mean I think he
is a war criminal this ICC we have not
done that in the United States because
we're concerned about our soldiers or
people uh being brought under it but I
do think that he should be held
accountable so uh sort of sounds like
tough talk but a lot of the same caveats
uh that many of the soft Putin Defenders
will kind of reflexively go to including
he's not nearly as dangerous as some
claim him to be so sort of interesting
not in incredibly notable then appears
Morgan does ask DeSantis if you did run
do you think you can beat Trump I think
you can beat bud I think so I'm sorry do
you think you can beat Biden if you did
run I think you could beat bud I think
so so you're running them no I didn't
say that I just said I think I could I
mean I think that that's I mean if you
look at Florida it would be harder to be
Biden or Donald Trump workout
I don't know those are two Okay so
that is very interesting because if you
really do believe that in an election
against the sitting president of the
United States you would win it seems
very difficult to imagine getting away
from getting involved in that race no
matter what the primary polling says so
that's going to uh remain remain to be
seen
um Peters Morgan did ask Ron DeSantis
about allegations
that he backed the force-feeding of
prisoners while serving at Guantanamo
Bay DeSantis says it's not true but he
gets a little mushy-mouthed about it one
of the things I said was that you
authorize the use of force-feeding that
somebody yeah that's not true yeah any
of the stuff that people must have
finished it Force feeding the detainees
they were on Hunger Strike was that true
so I was a I was a junior officer I
didn't have authority to authorize
anything there may have been a commander
that would have done feeding if someone
was going to die but that was not
something that I would have even had
authority to do so that's that's wrong
yeah yeah absolutely okay uh and by the
way DeSantis is saying it's it's a raw
it's wrong to claim he did it not that
it's wrong to do the force feeding and
then lastly asked about Tick Tock and
I'll just play this one for you here
would you ban tick tock
I think so would you I think so I mean I
think from everybody in America I think
I think it's a security risk I think
they are harvesting so much data on our
citizens there's a whole bunch of other
apps and stuff that are out there and
honestly Pierce I got young kids I don't
want our kids on some of this stuff
would you okay so he would indeed ban
Tick Tock listen the danger with
DeSantis is he although he's incredibly
low energy and low charisma
he very casually will present ideas as
though yeah you know yeah yeah okay yeah
and so you always sort of come away like
well he doesn't seem very ideological
because like it sounds like he's sort of
like softly in this camp but he could
easily be pulled over here this is
really the trick of DeSantis where then
when you look at his actual record it's
this wacky anti-woke delusion fighting
the culture wars and extraordinarily
authoritarian as we've covered before so
a very interesting interview because it
shows us the DeSantis that he would
present to the world if he were to run
and it's this very down Earth yeah yeah
I'm a reasonable guy yeah yeah I would
do that I probably would yeah so it
makes sense sure yeah now Putin's bad
but yeah you know he's not really that
bad and that doesn't really have that
much that much power and then the
actions with DeSantis are really the
scary things so a very interesting
interview to see I'm sure there will be
more
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com join pacman.com
a number of you sent me a clip of
congresswoman Corey Bush claiming that
red states have higher rates of murder
and higher rates of gun deaths and that
is absolutely true and I'm going to go
over some of the data with you now this
is relevant because the story that the
right loves to tell is how red states
are safer and red cities are safer and
blue States and blue cities run by
democrats are just riddled with crime
and they're dangerous and that's really
where all of the violence is let's first
listen to what Corey Bush said then
we're going to look at some of this data
in 2020 per capita murder rates were 40
percent higher in States won by Donald
Trump than those won by Joe Biden nine
of the ten states with the highest gun
mortality rates including my state of
Missouri are red States
Mr Wilcox first of all thank you for
your strong well-informed advocacy
I want to build on Mr nadler's question
can you explain how the iron Pipeline
and weak Republican laws of gun laws
disproportionately harm black and brown
communities
uh yes ranking member and thank you for
the question
um as as you stated what we see pretty
clearly from examining gun laws and
looking at rates of gun violence is
states with stronger gun laws see less
gun violence uh why is that it's because
it's too easy for guns to be illegally
diverted from legal Commerce responsible
law-abiding citizens into gun
trafficking channels what are the ways
that that happens no background check
gun sales straw purchasing okay so now
they go into a number of the ways in
which we could strengthen uh gun laws
but so is this the truth you know
anecdotally we keep hearing frequently
now when Republicans talk about New York
City the accurate statement that the
violence rate or the violent crime rate
is higher in Oklahoma City than it is in
New York City Oklahoma City a red City
in a red State compared to New York City
a blue City in a blue state but this is
actually a bigger Trend so let's look at
a couple of different things if you look
at the 2020 homicide rate and if you're
looking there's a graph here where you
have states with the highest homicide
rates at the top right
and lower uh homicide rates as you go
down to the bottom left you see that the
states with the highest homicide rates
are Mississippi Louisiana Alabama
Missouri Arkansas South Carolina
Tennessee Maryland Illinois New Mexico
Georgia you have this gradient wherein
the homicide rates are notably higher in
red States you then go to Firearms
mortality
and you see a very similar story the
highest death rate from Firearms is
Mississippi Louisiana Wyoming Missouri
Alabama Alaska blue state of New Mexico
followed by Arkansas South Carolina
Tennessee Montana Oklahoma Kentucky West
Virginia Georgia Idaho Indiana Nevada
Kansas
finally getting to Arizona okay so there
is no doubt whatsoever that that is the
truth it doesn't matter how you slice
and dice the State numbers now how would
the right react to this well one of the
things that the right says when
presented with this information one of
the things they say is the numbers
aren't true it's fake news we can't
believe it it's all nonsense you made
that up okay if you can get them to
acknowledge these numbers
they will often say well but the crimes
are mostly in the cities within those
states which are blue
now that's not actually true it is true
as a general rule that people on the
left in the United States are more
likely to live in urban areas and people
on the right are more likely to choose
to live rurally and Suburban it's sort
of a mix depending on the states that
you're in that is absolutely true but in
general rates of crime uh can follow
where people are closer together but by
looking at rates we actually account for
that and there have been studies done
that say okay fine you can look at these
cities if you want
and there are very high numbers of
crimes because of the number of people
but you can chart these very large rural
areas that cross many states uh on a map
and as far as rates of crimes go they
are still very high in those rural areas
it's just that the absolute numbers are
lower because there are fewer people but
the truth is if we want to be more
serious about this there is no one
answer to this is it true that red
States on average having more relaxed
gun laws increases gun deaths yes it is
true and also it is true
that if you live in Chicago which is a
blue City in a blue state
which has strict gun laws you can very
easily drive 40 minutes over into
Indiana or what is it like 55 60 minutes
into Wisconsin potentially
states with more relaxed gun laws so it
it's not everything is Shades of Gray
the gun accessibility is a factor but it
also impacts blue states that are in
proximity to Red States poverty is a
major factor poverty is higher in red
States education is a factor education
is worse in red States cultural
attitudes towards using guns to solve
problems
I I'm I don't have data on what the
differences are between blue and red
States on that but it is a factor in a
if you had states where culturally it's
considered more appropriate to fight to
use physical violence or to use guns to
resolve interpersonal problems well
that's going to be a factor for sure
infrastructure and Economic Opportunity
which we know is lower in red States GDP
per capita lower in red States all of
these elements are factors and many of
them actually are sort of a feedback
loop where some cause others and in turn
the worsening of those others comes back
and worsens the initial causes proximate
and ultimate causes are definitely
something that needs to be considered
but the numbers really don't lie it
really is the case that gun mortality
rates remember rate accounts for
population the rates of gun mortality on
average higher in red States the murder
rate on average higher in red States
they don't like to admit it when they do
they find some other way to blame the
left but this is the reality in which we
live this is a super interesting short
clip I want to play for you Rhonda
McDaniel the head of the RNC the
Republican National Committee she
appeared on Fox news earlier today and
foxhost Stuart Varney was asking her
about the potential management by the
RNC of the Trump DeSantis primary that
might be coming but it might not we
don't know and Rana descent this uh
Ronald McDaniel Rana DeSantis Ronald
McDaniel straight up admits that she has
no control over the that primary and one
of the things I've talked about is how
damaging to the eventual Republican
nominee will a really ugly primary be I
think to some degree a really ugly
primary will hurt whoever whoever comes
out on top and faces the Democratic
nominee Ronald McDaniel admits this is
beyond her to control it and then she
does a little what about ISM how are you
going to manage this clash between Trump
and the status
Stewart I would be lying if I said I'm
going to be able to manage this there's
going to be sharp elbows there'll be a
heated primary process what I will say
is we have to keep our eyes on the prize
we need to remember that 70 000 people
just died of overdoses our border is
open Crime is up we of course the border
is not open Crime overall is down and
it's significantly higher as we just
talked about in red States and red
cities our energy is up inflation is
killing middle income families gas
prices have come down significantly
inflation is at its lowest point since
2021.
and this is coming under the Biden
Administration so we can have a heated
primary but at the end of the day we
have to come together if we're going to
beat Biden and that's where I'm going to
be as RNC chair always focusing on the
end game which is winning the White
House and that's really the question she
is right about that at the end of the
day the question is how does the
Republican Party defeat Joe Biden or
whoever is the Democratic nominee
remember officially we still don't know
who the Democratic nominee will be
that's the fundamental question at the
end of the day and my question is
if DeSantis got out of the way it would
become obvious Trump will be the nominee
does that help the Republican primary by
allowing Trump to start campaigning now
in some way
I don't know if Trump were to be
indicted four times and drop out and it
becomes clear DeSantis is the leader or
at least that there's going to be a
contested primary not involving Trump is
that a better Republican primary for the
purposes of Republicans ultimately
winning in November of 2024. my instinct
is that a very ugly Republican primary
will dissuade some Republican voters
from coming out in November of 24. but
I don't know how big that impact will be
so my question to you is let me know in
a comment send an email send a tweet
however you want to get in touch
does the Republican nominee whoever it
will be benefit more from an easy and
smooth primary win or an ugly and
extended and contested primary win let
me know what you think we'll do a
follow-up soon based on people's
reaction we'll take a very quick break
and be back with much more
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Donald
Trump is now openly begging for money in
an orange conspiracy rant and a bunch of
his loser followers are giving him the
money why would you give a supposed
billionaire a little bit of cash because
of his claim that he's getting arrested
well we'll get to that this is an
unbelievable video unbelievable video
called dismantle the Deep State and
reclaim our democracy we'll remind you
what the Deep state is but this is open
conspiracy stuff from the failed former
president it is scary it is dystopian
and it is where we are in 2023
shockingly so take a listen to this from
agenda 47. here's my plan to dismantle
of the deep State and reclaim our
democracy from Washington corruption
remember he's a former president the
idea now of oh I'm I'm an outsider and
dude you were the president of the
United States how are you an outsider of
any kind once and for all and Corruption
it is first I will immediately reissue
my 2020 executive order restoring the
president's authority to remove Rogue
bureaucrats and I will wield that power
very aggressively remember what that is
is about being able to fire
government employees who are outside the
immediate political realm like secretary
of state right new president comes in
you replace the Secretary of State but
what Trump wants because he believes
that every random employee of the state
department or at least I'm sorry of the
federal government uh including the
state department and others is against
him he wants to be able to come in and
just say fire tens of thousands of
people Insanity in terms of the
disjointed Interruption that it would be
to the way so many government
departments function second we will
clean out all of the corrupt actors in
our national security and intelligence
apparatus what he means by that is
intelligence agencies don't seem to
agree with Trump's unhinged lies and so
he wants to get him out of there and
there are plenty of them
the Departments and agencies that have
been weaponized will be completely
overhauled so that faceless bureaucrats
will never again be able to Target and
persecute conservatives quick which they
weren't doing missions or the left's
political enemies which they're doing
now at a level that nobody can believe
even possible
third we will totally reform fisa courts
which are so corrupt that the judges
seemingly do not care when they are lied
to
in warrant applications this is a
personal grievance of trump this is
grievance politics Trump doesn't like
that there was enough evidence against
some of the people in his 2016 campaign
such that fisa warrants were signed by
judges that he's like just change the
process so many judges have seen so many
applications that they know were wrong
or at least they must have known they do
nothing about it they're lied to Fourth
to expose the hoaxes and abuses of power
that have been tearing our country apart
we will establish a Truth and
Reconciliation Commission to declassify
and publish all documents on deep State
spying censorship and Corruption now
this this talking point we looked at and
on a different day which Trump is now
repeating truly orwellian very often we
people say orwellian and it's not
orwellian this is orwellian and there
are plenty of them fifth we will launch
a major Crackdown on government leakers
who collude with the fake news to
deliberately we false narratives and to
subvert our government and our democracy
and as I told you yesterday
extraordinarily chilling in terms of
what it means for journalism and then we
get to the begging for money 100
000 government positions could be moved
out and I mean immediately of Washington
to places filled with Patriots who love
America and they really do love America
ninth I will work to ban Federal
bureaucrats from taking jobs at the
companies they deal with and that they
regulate so they deal with these
companies and they regulate these
companies and then they want to take
jobs from these companies doesn't work
that way such a
public display cannot go on and it's
taking place all the time like with big
Pharma finally I will push a
constitutional amendment to impose term
limits on members of Congress this is
how I will shatter the Deep State and
restore government that is controlled by
the people and for the people really
crazy 10-point plan thank you very much
yeah so this was sent out in a
fundraising email and we're going to get
to the fundraising aspect in a moment
let's actually discuss the Deep State
thing just for a moment for those who
aren't familiar with it the Deep state
conspiracy theory is again one of these
elitist cabal type conspiracy theories
the idea is government officials Elites
rich people transnational
Elites of different kinds they're
operating behind the scenes to
manipulate and control world events it
often implies that these individuals are
doing so against the interests of the
general public and that they are
responsible for many of the world's
problems now there's very little
evidence to support the existence of a
deep state
speculation
conjecture
misinterpreting isolated incidents or
events
what is true is that as a general
concept rich people and corporations
wield lots of power in Western societies
that's true
they go way further into this
puppeteer-like conspiracy unified
coordinated group of individuals and the
truth of course is that there are
agendas and there are competing
interests in government out of
government in the U.S in Europe in
different parts of the world oftentimes
deep state conspiracy
overlaps with globalist conspiracy One
World Government New World Order and all
of it is dripping in anti-Semitism that
Trump is now regularly and openly
claiming he's going to fight the Deep
state which has it in forum is really
wacky when it comes to remembering that
this is a former president but here's
the crazy part it's working to get
people to give them money Trump's fans
sent him a million and a half dollars in
three days after he falsely claimed he'd
get arrested Tuesday and that Soros and
the Deep state had it in for them let's
talk about that next
in 2023
if you still support Donald Trump
you deserve to have every penny drained
from your bank account if you're giving
them money if that's what happens to you
or what you decide to do
Donald Trump's fans sent him a million
and a half dollars in three days after
he falsely predicted he would be
arrested on Tuesday
a fool and their money are soon parted
does that apply here
Business Insider reports Trump wasn't
arrested but he got a big fundraising
boost raising 1.5 million dollars into
three days after saying he'd be arrested
that's nearly double the daily average
he got in the weeks before and after
launching his 2024 bid
the campaign confirmed the sum to Fox
News the money was said to be raised
from Grassroots donations raising about
five hundred thousand a day is about
double what Trump was previously
averaging the Trump campaign brought in
11.8 million in the six weeks before the
announcement which averages out to about
280 000 a day
in the six weeks after Trump's
announcement he raised about 226
000 today but then he wrote they're
going to arrest me we need to protest
take the nation back Soros deep state
conspiracy and on and on and on
and then he started including videos
like the one we just looked at talking
about how he will dismantle the Deep
State he started including those videos
inside of fundraising emails and he said
we need your support donate so we can do
this if you're not doing well don't send
any money but if you can if you can
afford it please send me some money
it is incredible is it pejorative to say
that you would have to be moronic to
fall for this at this point in time
now you might be saying
what on Earth motivates an individual
to give money to a billionaire because
they claim they're about to be arrested
and argue that they are going to
dismantle the so-called deep State what
on Earth would motivate someone to give
that individual money
and you have to remember that this is a
cult
it is a cult where some in the cult
believe that Donald Trump was sent by
God to save the United States of America
from a cabal of democratic pedophiles
if you believe that
it's not a very far stretch to say
you're going to send a little bit of
money
and that is a big part of understanding
what is going on here and like I said at
this point if you are still a trump
supporter in 2023
it's it's really buy or beware and the
downside of course is I don't want to
see people hurt and for a lot of these
folks donating money it's probably their
Social Security money that's going to
Trump uh based on the average uh you
know the disproportionately advanced age
of trump supporters
um and the financial reality of many of
these folks the other aspect to this of
course is that there's a long history I
mean go back to the tea party you can go
back longer but at least in the modern
era go back to the tea party and you
will remember people who will never
benefit from lowering taxes on the rich
voting in favor of candidates who want
to lower taxes on the rich why doesn't
make sense it's the same thing with
Trump supporting a guy who isn't going
to do anything that's going to help you
Jonathan height has really done a lot of
very good Research into this it is not
about voting for what I think is best
for me it's about voting for what I have
been convinced or tricked into believing
this is now my editorializing of it what
I have if if I can be tricked into
believing that what's based best for my
entire group
is to support someone like Trump or a
candidate that will lower taxes on the
rich I will vote that way
for group cohesion even if most of the
members of that group won't actually
benefit for the thing that they are
voting in favor of you have to
understand that to understand why
someone at this point would say I'll
donate to Trump and I'll vote for Trump
even though he's supposedly a
billionaire and his policies won't
actually do anything for me read
Jonathan Heights work on that and it'll
be very Illuminating
Trump capitalizing on the arrest claim
will he pay his lawyers I don't know
will he actually get arrested next week
I don't know I'm waiting to see just as
much as you are we have a voicemail
number which you can call anytime that
number is
2192 David P here is a caller who is
called in after he figured out I am not
a Christian and he has some Choice words
for me I will tell you that
ah hey David yeah when I I'm just
watching your mouth on this TV here and
you saying that them prose testers
the proofs testers yes we're outside of
the Donald Punk building when they were
outside of the courthouse that you you
don't even
well there were different videos and
some they were in one place and some
they were in the other
well
well I've done figured out because you
admitted yourself you're not a Christian
that's true and you know what that makes
me so happy today here because
there is a God there is a Jesus there is
a Holy Spirit and Satan is going to be
coming here Satan real soon pray tending
to be Jesus
and little waste of sperms like you are
going to follow I hope so I want you to
follow that piece of all the way to
the Lake of Fire right along with Donald
Funk okay well very very powerful
declaration and uh be aware Satan will
come back pretending to be Jesus very
very soon certainly something to be
scared of on the bonus show today we are
going to talk about the truth of
Manhattan district attorney Alvin
Bragg's alleged ties to billionaire
George Soros what are the ties do they
exist are they what Republicans claim
them to be we will explore secondly
Disney World after everything that
happened in Florida with Rhonda Santos
they don't say gay Bill taking away
Disney's uh rights there in that
neighborhood District that they have
after all of it is said and done
Disney is hosting a major Summit on gay
rights they seem really intimidated by
DeSantis guys we'll talk about that and
lastly the FED again raised interest
rates yesterday This Time by 25 basis
points despite the stress hitting the
banking system but in a context where we
are being led to believe that the fed's
work is seemingly close to done in this
cycle of interest rate increases where
are we what do we expect what is the
impact of raising versus lowering the
federal funds rate we're going to go
over all of it my friends on today's
bonus show sign up for membership at
joinpakman.com you will get instant
access to the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad Alex Jones despises
the bonus show but actual members love
it you can sign up at joinpakman.com you
can use the coupon code indict to say
save yourself significantly off of the
cost of membership we will see you then
and then we'll be back tomorrow with the
Friday show